لقي الممثل الامريكي بول وكر الذي بزغ
نجمه في فيلم السرعه والغضب فاست اند
فيورس حتفه عن 40 عاما فجر الاحد في حادث
سياره جنوب كاليفورنيا واكدت وفاته وكيله
اعماله امي فان ايدن لكنها رفضت الادلاء
بتفاصيل تزيد عن تلك التي نشرت بالموقع
الرسمي للنجم السينمائي على موقعي فيسبوك
وتويتر وبحسب المنظمه الخيريه التابعه
لوكر ريش اوت ذا ورد فان انه كان بصحبه
صديق له في سيارته اثناء توجههما الى حفل
خيري للمنظمه في سانتا كلاريتا ومن جانبه
قال قائد شرطه سانتا كلاريتا فالي ان
سياره من طراز بورش يبدو ان سائقها فقد
السيطره عليها وكانت مشتعله سعه وصول
افراد الامن وقد عثر على الراكبين بداخلها
متوفيين ومن المفارقات ان ووكر الذي يبلغ
من العمر 40 عاما اشتهر نجمه في فيلم
الاثاره فاست اند فيورس الذي يدور حول
قياده السيارات بسرعه مفرطه ويظهر البطل
دائما في دور قائد السياره المحنك الذي
يقوم باستعراضات لقدراته في قياده
السياره وقد كان ووكر يعمل على الاعداد
لفيلمه السابع الذي كان من المقرر عرضه
العام
المقبل